good evening everybody and welcome to
tucker carlson tonight i am not tucker
i'm brian kilmeade and according to the
schedule i am in for tucker for at least
an hour it's hard to believe that it's
been nearly a month since joe biden
promised to evacuate every american from
afghanistan any american who wants to
come out we will get you home he said
that it's a talking point that many
administration officials have continued
to repeat the administration's allies
people like senator chuck schumer saying
it too for example i'll put this in
quotes because he said it joe biden
rescued every american from afghanistan
isn't that interesting it was an
extraordinary success they continued to
insist but is it true
no it's not true at least according to
biden's own state department just today
secretary of state anthony blinken
muttered his way through a press
conference saying that the taliban is
not allowing charter flights to depart
hamad karzai international airport in
kabul
as of now
the taliban are not permitting the
charter flights to depart
they claim that some of the passengers
do not have the required documentation
while there are limits to what we can do
without personnel on the ground without
an airport with normal security
procedures in place
we are working to do everything in our
power to support those flights
and to get them off the ground
at another time we'll go over why we
don't have anyone on the ground and
we're not having any control of
anybody's airport but that's for another
show what anthony blinken didn't say is
those fights include american citizens
though it's not clear how many over the
weekend white house chief of staff ron
klain said there were approximately 100
american citizens left in afghanistan
about a week ago lincoln said it was
anywhere from 100 to 200 these numbers
likely don't include green card holders
since even the administration doesn't
have a clear number how of how many of
them are actually in afghanistan what
blinking also didn't mention was that
the taliban aren't the only ones
blocking fights from leaving afghanistan
fox news has obtained an exclusive email
showing the state department is blocking
flights as well the emails are from a
retired marine named eric montalvo who
is operating his own private evacuation
flight from afghanistan flights i should
say it's plural according to those
emails the state department is refusing
to give charter flights approval to land
in other countries the state department
also told montalvo the private flights
would not be allowed to land at the
department of defense bases
even though they were transporting
american citizens and those are american
bases quote you need to find another
destination country and it can't be the
u.s either well isn't that nice
none of this is stopping afghan refugees
from arriving in the u.s however
according to general glenn varhark
i should say of u.s northern command
less than half of the afghan refugees
coming to the u.s are special immigrant
visa applicants who we kind of want gear
there are thousands of afghans we know
little to nothing about that are coming
here yet they're allowed to land on u.s
bases in our country
according to a recent report one male
afghan refugee was recently detained at
ramstein air base in germany after
explosive material and blasting caps
were found in his carry-on luggage
before he boarded his flight to
ramstein u.s officials reportedly
believed the materials related to his
work and not terrorism is his job to be
a terrorist just a thought but he was
still placed on a restricted list now
normally all of this would be a crisis
for the state department and they'd be
focused on fixing it right but officials
at the department are a little busy with
apparently more pressing matters for
example the number of women in the
taliban's new government
yesterday a statement to the hill a
state department spokesperson expressed
concern about the lack of female
leadership in afghan afghanistan's new
interim government could it be the
taliban doesn't really like women too
much doesn't give them jobs but i
digress quote we have made clear our
expectation that afghan people deserve
an inclusive government wow you talk
about a strongly worded statement that
will get everybody's attention the bind
administration is already familiar with
at least some of the new government
senior leaders why because we already
caught him on the battlefield and then
released him remember this the new
taliban senior officials were gitmo
detainees that former president obama
traded for a traitor a former u.s army
sergeant named bo bergdahl was back in
2014. at that time susan rice by the way
she's still playing in the white house
said the most important thing was
bergdahl's well-being and not the fact
that four terrorists had just been
released
back into the taliban leadership
he served the united states with honor
and distinction and we'll have the
opportunity eventually to to learn what
has transpired in in the past years but
what's most important now is his health
and well-being that he had the
opportunity uh to recover in peace and
security and be
reunited with his family and eventually
be tried for treason but i digress
president obama also insisted there was
nothing to worry about let's listen we
will be keeping eyes on them
is there the possibility
of
uh some of them trying to return to
activities that are detrimental to us
absolutely that's been true of
all the
prisoners that were released from
guantanamo there's a certain recidivism
rate that takes place
i wouldn't be doing it if i thought that
it was contrary to
american national security well it is
and you did it anyway it turns out it
was contrary to american national
security the former gitmo detainee is
now holding the following government
positions in afghanistan jot these down
acting minister for information and
culture acting minister of borders and
tribal affairs acting defense minister
the acting director of intelligence of
course all this pens on senate
confirmation also abdul haq with sikh
returns to a position he held with the
taliban before the 9 11 attacks hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else